the centers for disease control and
prevention was once widely viewed as the
gold standard in public health
considered an apolitical science-driven
bulwark against all pathogen threats
foreign and domestic the first case of
the deadly chinese coronavirus making
its way to the u.s
the federal government and public health
system have been preparing for an
outbreak like this for years and because
of the prep the cdc remains vocal that
americans do not have to fear exposure
today trust in the agency has plummeted
because covet 19 exposed the truth the
cdc is thoroughly corruptable and
federal regulators will never be
impartial experts they respond to
political incentives just like everyone
else and a fact-driven purely
technocratic state is an impossible
dream when you do testing to that extent
you're gonna find more people you're
gonna find more cases
so i said to my people slow the testing
down please
the trump administration pressured the
cdc to narrow the scope of testing so
case counts would drop blocked officials
from doing interviews and edited its
flagship scientific reports the cdc
provided a scientifically dubious public
health rationale for rejecting migrants
at the southern border biden continued
that policy and under his purview cdc
guidance on school closures was
surreptitiously written by leaders of
the country's second largest teachers
union from day one of this outbreak
the lack of organization and management
from the central government from the
trump administration has been shocking
former cdc director tom frieden
co-authored an op-ed with three other
former agency heads expressing hope that
biden's incoming cdc director rochelle
walensky would restore the public's
confidence in the cdc's scientific
objectivity with its reputation a shadow
of what it once was
yet frieden endorsed large-scale
protests against racial injustice two
months after writing in the washington
post that the faucet of everyday
activities needs to be turned on slowly
we cannot open the floodgates
meanwhile public health officials were
keeping people from attending the
funerals of their loved ones
just a few days ago the center for
disease control and prevention
issued a new mass guidelines
under the new guidelines most americans
and most of the country
can now go mask free covet 19 no longer
need control our lives
and could it be purely coincidence that
the cdc chose the friday before
president biden's state of the union
address to drop its indoor mask
recommendation for the majority of
americans even though the supporting
data were months old in other words it
doesn't matter who occupies the white
house political incentives mean that no
matter how dedicated or competent the
career scientists who work at the cdc
are
the agency will never be controlled by
fact-driven experts shielded from the
hurry and strife of politics as woodrow
wilson wrote
after decades of mission creep the cdc's
role should be strictly narrowed limited
to surveillance and coordination leaving
the heavy lifting to local officials and
private and academic researchers who are
more reactive to direct feedback from
their communities in 2007 former agency
director james mason noted that of
course the cdc is going to have some
political oversight and political
influence it's inherent and necessary
but he stressed that it's the
responsibility of cdc leadership to
stand up to political interests when
necessary
during the pandemic that didn't happen
not only did the agency consider
political factors when making what were
most often presented as purely
science-based decisions but officials
frequently hid ignored or distorted
legitimate data either out of
incompetence or to appease their
political bosses the cdc has also been a
super spreader of coveted misinformation
my job was to tell america that i'm
leading with the science the evidence is
clear
mass can help prevent the spread of
covet 19 by reducing your chance of
infection by more than 80 percent
regardless of what the antigen test said
we would say you still need to wear your
mask its information would not be useful
to justify universal mask mandates
wallenski spent months citing a junk
study on their efficacy in schools
exaggerating the risks of breakthrough
infections among the vaccinated and
misrepresenting a study on outdoor kova
transmission according to its author the
cdc claimed the delta variant was as
transmissible as chickenpox which isn't
true it turns out the agency had used
inaccurate data from a new york times
infographic it also promoted an
infographic on cloth masks using data
that were not statistically significant
meanwhile the cdc has not run a single
randomized controlled trial on the
efficacy of masking since the beginning
of the pandemic in the vaccine rollout
the cdc told the elderly they needed to
wait in line behind essential workers
including young and healthy school
support staff corporate tax lawyers and
magazine fashion editors
in its noble zeal to convince parents to
get their children vaccinated the cdc
used old data that the agency knew were
no longer valid to falsely claim
hospitalizations were rising among
adolescents
it misrepresented a study to exaggerate
the dangers faced by unvaccinated
children and it falsely claimed that
kids who get covet are more likely to
develop diabetes
under both the trump and biden
administrations the cdc publicly cast
doubt on the value of n95 masks vaccines
and diagnostic tests at times when there
were supply shortages or when it was
politically expedient both presidents
even used the cdc to exert federal
control over state-level housing policy
repeatedly extending an unconstitutional
ban on evictions based on junk science
nor is this laundry list of blunders and
machinations that put politics ahead of
public health unusual for the modern cdc
an agency that began as a post-world war
ii effort to eradicate malaria in the
united states but now is in charge of
investigating everything from car
accidents to sports injuries to gun
violence to teen vaping
despite having a budget that's 14 times
larger than it was in the late 80s today
cdc is less prepared than ever to
address its founding purpose controlling
infectious disease once the politicians
in charge learn that they can gain
influence and funding for pet issues by
couching them as important for americans
health there's no end to what arenas
they will task public health officials
with a certain control over the cdc was
once a poster child for the movement by
many federal entities in the 1970s
toward an approach known as regulatory
science which aimed to create impartial
standards for regulatory action that
would be evidence-based and apolitical
and therefore trustworthy and consistent
but none of these reforms changed the
underlying incentives of the cdc or
other agencies or of their political
overseers the public choice implications
remain the same politicians want to look
good to voters bureaucrats depend on
politicians for their job and so
bureaucrats will do what it takes to
make politicians look good no matter how
unmoored from objective data a
particular favored policy may be
political concerns also make the cdc
structurally incentivized to be overly
cautious making its officials slow to
act in a crisis and reluctant to look
outside the agency for help this is what
led to the cdc's greatest blunder at the
beginning of the pandemic when it banned
academic private and non-profit
laboratories from developing diagnostic
tests delaying their arrival by at least
two months and leaving both government
and private scientists blind to the
spread of the virus
when the agency finally released its own
test it was poorly designed prone to
contamination and inaccurate
outbreaks of zika and ebola remind us
that health threats are not limited to
one country one issue or one pathogen
none of this was unpredictable even
after the cdc got a chance to stress
test its crisis response during the h1n1
swine flu virus outbreak of 2009. it
failed to address known shortages of n95
masks ventilators and other critical
medical equipment partly due to
political interference by the obama
administration you know 60 million
americans got h1n1 uh in that period of
time and it's just purely a fortuity
that this isn't one of the great mass
casualty events in american history had
nothing to do with us doing anything
right just had to do with luck
uh and so if anyone thinks that this
can't happen again
uh they have to go back to 1918 they
just have to go back to 2009 2010. in an
even more recent harbinger of what was
to come during the zika virus outbreak
starting in 2016 the cdc mishandled the
development of a diagnostic test while
shutting out commercial manufacturers so
how do we stop another predictably
disastrous response before the next
pandemic
even serious proposals that add on more
layers of oversight and red tape are
doomed from the start these attempts
only add greater scope for lobbyists and
politicians to exert influence and
exploit loopholes such reforms miss the
fundamental reality that centralizing
control over public health especially at
the federal level necessarily results in
sclerosis risk aversion and mission
creep
today we can see the costs in thousands
of lives lost unnecessarily and
americans are finally fed up but the
pandemic did not create this reality it
simply exposed it we can look to
examples of localized distributed public
health systems in other countries that
proved themselves during the pandemic
consider what the outcome might have
been here if the cdc hadn't monopolized
testing early on and instead taken a cue
from its south korean counterpart after
confirming their first four covet 19
infections health officials there rushed
to work with biotech companies on a
diagnostic test and were able to deploy
it within a single week
in germany government health authorities
partnered with private labs around the
country to create a broad testing
network early on and rapid tests were
available in vending machines while the
u.s was still struggling through supply
shortages perhaps most importantly
countries whose public health
authorities were transparent and
maintained the public's trust have seen
much higher rates of voluntary
participation in vaccination and other
efforts to stem the community spread of
the virus cdc veteran dr martin cetron
has warned colleagues for years of a
phenomenon he terms a bankruptcy of
trust when people no longer place their
faith in public officials allowing
speculation and misinformation to fill
the void now that the pandemic is
functionally over it's clear that the
cdc has long been on the path toward its
utter failure to plan for or to
competently address the foundational
reason for its existence and americans
have good reason to rethink their
confidence in the federal government's
ability to protect their health